。
同学们好啊，咱们上课。
上节课呢布置了一个作业，对吧？
让大家根据这个这个。
绿野仙踪和菊次郎的夏天。
这两个片子的结构。
你自己尝试练习着写一个。
公路片。
要求呢以你自己为原型，按照咱们商业片的节拍去去去写，然后最后达到。
其实都是我的这么一个。
合题对吧？
这个这个。
很多同学已经写了啊，我已经看到有很多同学交作业了。
在这个交作业的平台上。
编剧学习啊你就是得写得列。然后呢，这样咱们才能发现问题。
这节课呢咱们就根据同学们。
这个作业里面出现了问题。
讲一个比较实用的小技巧吧，讲一个实用的技巧。
啊，有些同学问啊，说这个作业咋交？
我上次直播的时候，有很多同学问说，哎，这个老师你光布置作业，这个作业咋交？
问这个问题，很显然你是还没有进入我们的。
学习群。
咱们这个课是有学习群的啊，里面已经有几万个同学了。
分好多好多班级。
这个呃同学们如果想深度参与学习啊，参与学习和交流啊，可以去加那些学习群啊。
这个很多同学没加，我也理解，因为网上啊凡是让你加群的。
很多都是。
都是要骗你点啥，对吧？
嗯，确实有这样，我新闻不是还有一个嘛，说那个那个有个群。
呃，300人。
299个是托儿，就进去一个杀猪盘，你知道吧？就进去一个。
被骗的。
这种情况确实很多啊，而且网上十有八九是这种。但是咱们的学习全不是啊。
咱们的学习群主要用来干啥呢？
咱们的学习群首先是都是咱们的同学，而且也是由咱们的同学组成的班委会在运营这些群里边主要在干啥呢？
主要是。
学习交流啊呃这个圈子里面的这个资讯的交流呀，对吧？或者大家岗位互补互助呀，组成团队呀。
然后还有就是。
呃，有作业。
有打卡，有考试，有进阶的考试。
还有这个更重要的是有招聘会。
因为咱们这个学员规模大了之后吧，有很多影视公司，大的影视公司呢会跟咱合作，在咱的学习群里招聘。
呃，当然也是通过考试呀、面试呀这种方式。
我们很多同学就就通过这些招聘会已经入行了嘛。所以说这个学习群的作用还是。
作用很很大的啊。
这个这个你们有兴趣的话，就可以参加这些。
学习群因为都是同学们自主在运营啊，包括咱们学习群还成立影视公司了。
对吧因为这个这个班委会啊。
呃，现在这个。
人群足够大以后啊，资源也是很多的。所以嗯其实。
实机也成熟了。所以班委会呢成立了一个影视公司。
嗯。
还是那句话，同学们自己运营。
去办同学们的事儿，因为涌现出来很多优秀的同学又本你的商业化呀，这开发呀，是不是？所以呢成立一个影视公司。
嗯，我参与投资了，对吧？我投资，然后让同学们去去去整，我就不直接参与经营了，毕竟是同学们自己的事情。
所以说这么多呢，意思啥呢？就是咱们这个学习交流群，你。
你如果是这个这是这一行的人，或者是爱好者，是学生，你可以可以加进去。
看看能够。
能够得到些什么样的帮助吧，好吧。
啊，说回咱的作业。
这个交作业的这些同学，我看了一下啊。
嗯，有共性的问题。
所以这节课给大家讲一个这个。
算是剧本修改的小技巧。
叫关于剧本的。
攻击性。
剧本的攻击性。
这是修改技巧，你得先有剧本啊。
你得先写呀，对吧？上节课这个练习就是这个意义呀，你大家你得先写个东西出来。
有同学问啊，说老师你上节课给我们规定的太死了，先怎么样对吧？再怎么样，先是现状，然后远方的召唤痛打看门狗上路之后获取你缺失的东西什么。
1234的。
给我们整的限制太严格了，用我们山东篮球名宿巩小斌的名言啊，就是你怎么这么娇情啊。
你怎么这么狡条对吧？这句话在网上很火啊。
为什么这么教条呢？
啥意思呢啊？
上礼拜也有同学跟我讨论过这个问题。
我也是用篮球跟他解释这个事儿的。
就这个同学也跟我说，他说老师你看啊。
那个什么什么片子啊。
从剧本的角度，按照您的理论来说。
不太合格，因。
有巨大的漏洞。
但是呢你看人家哎票房不错哦。
对吧票房很好。
老师，你怎么看待这个问题？
是不是故事结构？有时候讲故事的逻辑，讲故事的方法。
也没那么重要。
这位同学给我提出这么一个问题。
我当时是咋回答他的呢？
因为他是个男孩啊，我就用篮球给他。
解释这个问题。我说你现在啊问我这个问题，就像。
你跑过来跟我说，老师。
你看过埃弗森打球。
艾弗森打球老猛了。
但是埃弗森好像不符合老师你说的要求。
你看艾弗森。
个儿不高。
是吧老师你说打篮球最好个儿高，对吧？艾弗森个儿不高，然后嘞。
突破形式比较单一，就爱往右涂。
对吧基本不往左突。
然后呢。
不怎么爱打配合团队意识呢？
不怎么强。
最重要的是什么？
艾弗森啊不爱训练。
哎，第二天有比赛，今天晚上照样去夜店喝大酒。
然后呢，异常砍个四五十分，我呃，然后我就跟这个同学说，我说你现在提的这个问题啊，就是这么个情况。
你觉得教练你说的是不是不对呀？你看艾弗森多猛，我要像艾弗森一样打球。
我说那你咋想？
你就打算从此以后不训练。
然后呢，不配合。
不讲战术。
不练技术。
比赛之前呢去喝大酒。
然后这样妄图用这种方式。
去参加比赛去击败艾弗森吗？
是不是这么个道理？
我就跟他说，我说你现在最大的问题就是你不是艾弗森。
你认为自己是f森。
这就是问题。
F森那叫什么？首先。
他有绝对的天赋。
第二。
他也并没有完全不训练啊，同学们啊完全不训练能运球能投篮吗？对不对啊？所以同学们一定要参加训练，一定要参加练习，不要认为自己天赋异禀，自己是F3，谁都得训练。而且咱话说回来啊。
我不会因为。
要求严格而扼杀任何1个F3的同学们。
咱们的同学中如果出了1个F3，我一眼就能看出来。
你如果。
第二天有比赛，你今天晚上就是违反我纪律，就是不训练，就是去喝大酒了。
我第二天。
也会让你上场的。
因为我知道有你在我能赢球，明白吗？
所以同学们不要去。
通过一些个例去去质疑我们的训练，去质疑我们的方法。
懂吗？
我们被质疑最多的啊，就在我的私信当中被质疑最多的。其实是我早期说的那个。
就女儿那个你们记得吗？
我说你看啊。
一般电影里面啊英雄都是救女儿。
女儿老婆老娘。
救女的不救男的对吧？然后啊。
很多同学就。
当时因为那个是比较早期的一个理论是吧？在早期的课程里面。
很多人听到那儿呢，就觉得这个老师过于教条。
对吧就不服啊，老想跟我辩论辩论，老想跟我争。
然后就甚至你看咱们上节课讲的菊次郎的夏天。
菊次郎带的是小男孩啊。
不是小姑娘，对吧？
这个这个很多同学就说你看老师，你是不是有点过于绝对了呢？
这个情况啊。
我还是跟大家讲。
女孩更能引起。
观众的共情它是个概率的问题。
你写女孩对你的片子。
打动人的几率更高是这么个意思。所以我推荐大家在练习的时候，或者是在你人生前几部作品的时候。
尽量的去。
既可以写男孩，又可以写女孩的时候，你写女孩。
这个计量呢我当时讲的时候，我也说过，有点无耻。
但是他真的很有用。
懂吧？
我可以给大家讲一个我真实经过的案例。
帮助大家理解为什么女孩。
会比男孩好讲一个真实的故事啊。
我年轻的时候。
二十五六岁吧。
20二十四五岁。
大学刚毕业没多久，刚进入社会。
挣了点钱，就刚进入社会的时候，算是挣了点钱吧，还谈不上第一桶金，就是挣了点钱脱贫了，这么去理解吧。
就是脱贫了。
就刚脱贫的时候啊。
人有点发飘。
有点发飘呢就会干点什么事呢？
就会去附庸风雅。
做慈善。
你知道吗？就觉得你知道要忆苦思甜呀。
毕竟咱也是穷苦出身嘛。
小时候家里条件不好，就觉得现在自己有钱了呢，就有点钱了呢，就想哎呀做点慈善，帮助一些贫困的小朋友。
当然盖不起希望小学了，但是能资助一些贫困的小孩，然后就去网上。
找了一个机构。
呃。
具体机构名我就不说了啊，咱也不能打广告。
叫什么什么花，反正这种花呢是一听就是。
西藏藏区高原上的花，你就知道它是。
资助那些西部的小朋友嘛，对吧？资助那些西部贫困地区的小朋友读书的一个。
这么一个平台。
然后我就去那个。
当时是用网站。
十几年前嘛还没有智能手机，在网站上呢就。
我就发现一个问题，就说你虽然写的是这个资助西部资助少数民族。
这个这个。
小朋友，但是呢上面的这个被资助对象啊，因为你可以自选，你知道吧？每个小孩的信息你可以自选。
我发现全是些。
汉族小朋友。
就是看名字，你就能看出来他是些汉族小朋友。
我就觉得有点奇怪。
我就联系他的客服。
我说诶。
咱们这个不是。
西藏的一个一个一个一个组织嘛，为什么这个上面的小朋友都是。
汉族校。
问他。
然后这个工作人员给我的回复是，他说资助藏族小朋友的话，你得礼拜一上午10点钟登录我们的网站。
为啥呢？因为我们每个礼拜一。
上新。
上新之后呢。
你的抢。
你过了礼拜一呢肯定就没了，你就抢不到了。
然后我就啊那就我就。
到了下一个礼拜一。
10点钟。
登录那个网站去蹲去蹲这个事儿。
然后等到10点1刷新果然上新了。
一大片。
藏族小朋友的名字。
然后呢，我还在这选呢，刷新了一下网页，我就发现。
所有的藏族小女孩。
全都没了。
然后再一刷新，再一犹豫，所有的藏族小男孩又都没了。
然后再过了一会儿呢，再再一看。
汉族小女孩也都没了。
最后剩下的全是。
汉族小南。
也就是它的顺序是什么呢？
他被摘牌的顺序是什么呢？
藏族小女孩。
藏族小男孩，汉族小女孩，汉族小男孩，年龄小的小孩，年龄大的小孩，基本上是从藏汉女男小大这么一个顺序被选走的。
这个事情对我刺激挺大的。
我当时就突然觉得自己。
好丑陋我。
明白这个意思吧？
本来是想做一件好事儿，自己挣了点钱，挺骚包的对吧？想。
资助一下人家。
但是呢。
全都是去抢。
藏族小女孩。
为什么同学们？
就是虚荣心呀。
你跟别人聊天聊起来的时候，哎，你也资助小朋友啊啊，对呀，我也资助西部的小朋友。那你资助那个小朋友叫什么名字呢？你说啊我那个一个叫柴旦卓玛，一个叫格桑平错。
你就很有面子，你知道吗？然后你就问，那你资助的叫什么名字呢？嗯，我那个一个叫陈浩南，一个叫赵山河。
听名字就一听就不是听名字就一听就好像不是很需要帮助的样子嘛。
对吧。
就啥意思呢？就是你去资助小朋友。
依然。
也是从。
弱小的。
女孩的年龄小的入手。
这就是我说的。
共情更愿意共情这种明白吗？
我承认这个很无耻，但是。
对于商业片来说，他就是这样的。
然后后来我就我也觉得自己这样做很不好。
我就把那个。
那个网站上滞销的。
差不多20个。
大龄男性汉族小朋友。
我一把都给包圆了。
自助了，我那时候一下是摘盘了2020个左右吧。
其实不贵啊，就是他们当年的生活费，一个月的生活费，学费就几百块钱。
资助了20个，一个月也不到1万块钱。其实。
现在想想当时真的是非常的可笑啊非常的可笑。但是社会就是这样，很现实。
所以呃我在课上呢经常给大家讲这些规矩啊，讲这些。
技法什么的。
我们同学一定要知道这件事情。
就是董其超说过嘛，写书法他讲过要熟而后生嘛，熟后生。
对吧。
就熟而后生。
啥意思呢？就是你开始练的时候啊，你要熟悉的掌握这种技法，掌握各种规矩。然后呢，等到你真写的时候呢，你再把这些技巧再忘掉。
像没有从来没有学过一样去写。
就可以了。
打篮球不也是这样吗？刚才说打篮球，我训练你们打篮球，教你们三步上篮，教你们怎么挡拆，教你们怎么打配合，怎么下快攻。但是真正上篮上了场以后。
打球的还是你呀。
明白吧？就是你熟练掌握那些技能以后啊，真正上了场之后，你不需要再背了。
不需要再背那些技巧啦。
对吧你要是他妈从驾校出去，每次上路还要再背一下，哎呀，左脚离合右脚油门，那你这这就完了，对吧？所以说手后生就是这个道理。你在训练的学习的时候啊，尊重这些技巧。
执行这些技巧。
肯定是没毛病的。
所以说。
给大家多说这么几句啊。
回到咱们这课的内容。
同学们交交上来的这些作业啊，我发现有一个普遍的问题就是缺乏攻击性。
缺乏攻击性。这节课呢给大家讲讲剧本攻击性的。
增强剧本攻击性的一些小技巧，好吧。
增强剧本攻击性啊，它不是一个新的知识。咱们之前呢都讲过，只不过呢。
你没有从这个角度去思考过这个问题，我相当于这节课给大家提供一个新的角度去去去去修改你的剧本，或者是去加强你的剧本。好吧，从攻击性这个视角去研究一下你的剧本。我们说首先。
剧本攻击性攻击你的剧本啊。
有几个来源，其实咱们之前讲过了，就是阻力的来源。
攻击员。
就是你主力的几个来源。
阻力来自哪三方面来着？
环境。
对吧。
环境对手。
和你自己。
我们说。
阻力一般来自于。
这三个方面。
那么你的攻击员其实也在这三个方面。
环境，比如说。
自然环境。
是吧大自然啊，这是个大环境呀，就我们都处在自然环境当中，大自然这个环境还有社会环境，对吧？作为一个人，你在社会里面那立社会环境啊。
还有这个这个这个。
更具体一点呢，你这个主角所处的这个。
他身处的这个地方，其实是个场景，这个环境对吧？有时候一个场景。
他所经历的这些场景也是你的环境。
也就是说在环境。
这些都是可以。
带来攻击的。
你剧本缺乏攻击性啊，你的剧本就缺乏看点，看点少。
曲线不够。
跌宕起伏。
那么从环境的角度来。
大自然是不是可以给你的？
带来攻击。
对吧咱不说山崩地裂，下个雨刮个风很常见吧。你看很多电影里面。
这个关键时刻就下大雨。
就自然环境其实是要攻击你的呀。
对不对？然后社会环境不友好，这个也非常常见嘛，对吧？然后场景环境都会给你带来困扰。
这是也给你带来困扰。
然后我们说对手攻击你。
这个太正常了吧，对手就是专门来攻击你的呀。
那显然这也是一个重要的攻击攻击点。
在这里我们强调一下啊，因为我看了很多同学的这个作业啊，这个这个对手啊呃不要把对手理解为坏人啊，同学们。
千万不要把对手理解为坏人。
对手其实更。
更确切的一种理解，它其实是你的。
第。
一相关方。
对不对？
他是跟你利益对冲呀，我们不是说过那个那个我不是药神里边，周一围是最大的对手。但周一威人家不是坏人呀，人家是人民警察呀，人家做的事情是。
是无比正确的呀，他只不过跟你利益对冲。
懂吧？所以利益相关方、利益对冲方都是你的对手。
我不是还说过吗？我说你的伙伴啊，他如果自己有个事儿，他自己的这个事儿肯定与主角的主线目标相冲。
那他在那件事情上其实就是跟你利益。
相冲了。
他就在那件事情啊，你的伙伴转化成你的对手了，甚至你的爱情都可以转化成你的对手啊。
所以你的攻击员有很大一部分来自对手，这个很容易理解，对吧？
但是我们需要强调一下你的对手呃，你现在弄的不是很好，对手有几点要求啊，首先跟你利益相冲，这是肯定的。然后嘞。
一定不要把对手写的很傻。
因为对手的智商代表主角的智商。
对手智商低，主角智商就低。
这个一定要记住，你们去看那些抗日神剧。
那里面那些日本鬼子，那那都啥智商，对吧？日本鬼子如果要那个智商的话，咱需要八年抗战吗？
对不对啊？你把对手写的那么傻，你不是在侮辱对手。
你是在侮辱。
主角你是在侮辱你自己。
所以对手一定要高智商，对手对你的攻击一定要有层次，而且要逐级上升。我说过，对手做事情，对手要有自己的理念，有有自己的计划，对吧？而且这计划最好分不明确123，我先干嘛再干嘛再干嘛，有三步。
而且就对手这三步走就体现了他的层层逼近嘛。
他这三步啊最好都实现。
你明白这意思吧？对手的计划分三步，你不能在第一步啪就给他把计划。
熄灭了不可以，1二三步，他最好三步都实现了。
才能把主角逼向绝境嘛。所以这个关于这个对手啊，大家一定要。
注意一下，好吧，首先呢跟你利益对冲，然后呢，他要有智商，有目标，有计划，对吧？然后才能逐急破继。
明白吗？
然后自身这个也比较容易理解，对吧？就是你自己自己攻击你自己啊，你自己攻击。
自残嘛当然不是字面意义上的自残啊，就比如说你自己犯错了，对吧？你自己犯错了，或者你自己。
害怕了对吧？犯犯错误了，或者是害怕了，对吧？或者是犹豫了。
或者是这个这个季度了，或者是这个这个这个。
呃，误解了选择错误了，判断失误了，这些都是你自己给你自己带来的呃攻击。
我们说这个攻击员呀。
相对比较容易理解，对吧？
我们说可以像就是你的阻力嘛，从环境的角度，从对手的角度。
从你自身的角度来攻击。
那么就带来一个新的问题。
你攻击谁呢？
攻击目标呢。
对吧你攻击得有目标啊。
攻击源在这儿，那攻击目标是什么呢？
这个问题没有想明白，导致我们同学其实这个很好理解，对吧？我们之前说过呀，就是你这个这个主线剧情，你要设计阻力，阻力来自于什么呢？来自于环境，来自于对手，来自于自己。我们说过这个问题，那为什么你的剧情当中为什么这个剧剧情的攻击性还是那么低呢？是因为你没有解决一个攻击目标的问题？
攻击目标。
我们说攻击目标啊。
当然是攻击我们的主角，这个一定要记住，好吧，不要去攻击其他人。
不要去攻击其他人，攻击我们的主角。
攻击我们的主角。
这个一定要记住，或者攻击我们的主角群，对吧？
那攻击主角的什么呢？
我们来剖析一下。首先。
可以攻击主角什么？
首先可以攻击主角。
本身。
对吧攻击他这个人。
攻击主角这个人。
比如说攻击主角这个人啊，主角角色啊在戏中，他这个人身上有什么？
首先。
他有肉体吧。
对吧首先它是它是个肉身呀。
那公鸡肉身很就揍他吗？
伤害他呀。
这个很常见呀，那主角那哪个主角不遍体鳞伤的是吧？一场戏下来主角还有不受伤的那就很少嘛，攻击他的肉体，对吧？那攻击他的肉体，那顺便肯定还可以攻击他的精神，对不对不对？攻击他的精神。然后呢。
肉体精神都可以攻击，还可以攻击什么？你说这个主角还有什么？
缺陷。
攻击他的缺陷，对吧？攻击他的技能，主角不是还有技能吗？
对不对？
主角还有什么技能缺陷，还有什么？
还有。
枷锁常见的主角，还有枷锁呀，我们课上一直说的金箍咒吗？主角不是很多都有金箍咒吗？攻击他的金箍咒啊。
攻击他金箍咒。
是吧。
还可以攻击什么？
主角还有什么？还有身份攻击他的身份呀。
对不对？有些人甚至是假身份攻击他的假身份呀。
这些都可以被攻击。
对吧甚至我们说主角，比如说他的武器。
他的武器道具也可以被攻击，对吧？他的法器嘛，我们说主角在第二幕会得到法器嘛。
这都是主角身上东西可以被攻击的。
然后我说除了攻击主角本人以外，他这个人以外。
还可以攻击什么？经常被忽略的。
人物关系。
我们说主角的身边的人物关系网也是你的攻击。
目标呀。
对吧攻击他的爱情。
攻击他的伙伴，对吧？
攻击他的爱情，攻击他的伙伴，攻击他的师徒情。
攻击他的这个这个本身它与伙伴的差异。我们说伙伴是。
主角跟伙伴是互补的呀，互补就有差异啊。
对吧肯定是有理念上的差异呀，甚至都是不同阵营的，不同帮派的，不同种族的攻击他呀。
让他们之间产生误会。
产生摩擦。
甚至决裂。
对吧攻击他的人物关系。
我们说攻击大劲儿了，那就直接就失去了。
伙伴死了65分钟，伙伴死了，给他干死了。
对吧。
我们说你看。
攻击目标，攻击主角，可以攻击他的人，也可以攻击他的人物关系。但是攻击他的人，攻击他的人物关系，我们最终。
是想攻击什么呢？
最终。
归根到底，还是要攻击他的行动目标呀。
最终归根到底，攻击了还是他的行动目标。
所以你看。
你的剧本缺乏攻击性，是因为你没有理清楚攻击源来自于环境对手自己攻击目标。
攻击的是。
我们主角人本身。
他的人物关系以及他的行动目标。
这样理清楚了之后，你现在检查你手里的剧本是28课的作业也好，还是你以前写的也好，我们来捋一捋你的攻击攻击点全不全。
假设。
来，我们先看环境。
环境是攻击员，这里这里发波，这里往外发波打他好吧，从这里往那边攻击。
环境比如说第一个环境大自然。
大自然可以攻击谁？
我们说你看我们就往这边连线就可以了啊。
大自然可以攻击主角本身吧。
大自然可不可以攻击主角的肉体？
可以吧。
这个这个这个大自然出的这个这个出了点什么问题，树倒了，山上石头下来了，给主给主角腿干断主角行动的关键时刻，对吧？大自然给你当头一棒子。
可以有吧。
大自然折磨你的精神可以有吧。
大自然折磨你的缺陷有没有？
有啊，太多了呀。
我们说来常见的缺陷。
海贼王那个luy不会游泳。
怕水来怕水来水嘛。
你怕水，我们就来水嘛，发大水。
对吧大水拦路。
大自然攻击你的缺陷呀，你缺啥呢？攻击你啥呀？
对吧？
大自然也可以控击你的技能呀。
比如说你的技能是什么呢？
我们常见的技能，比如说神枪手是我们主角的常见技能吧。神枪手那大自然的起大悟了，啥也看不见，能见度没有了。
对吧冰雪豹里面冰雪报里面那个。
那个大雪。
大到完全没有能见度。
攻击你的技能。
让你的技能无效。
对吧同理大自然也可以攻击你的紧箍咒，攻击你的身份，攻击你的武器都可以，对吧？
它自然的水给你把雾器。
那个那个。
子弹都给弄湿了，打不着了，那你看咋整？
这就是你看从大自然角度。
可以攻击。
这么多，然后大自然来攻击人人物关系不行吗？
也可以啊。
大自然攻击你的目标不行吗？
然后社会环境可不可以攻击这些。
一样都可以再连一遍。
对吧。
攻击你的。
我们说社会环境。
就社会很复杂呀。
对吧很不友好呀，环境不友好。你看啊我说那个。
赵本山。
赵本山早期的电视剧，每一部只要他进城，立马丢钱包。
你去看一看，他只要进城立马就抢包。
就社会环境永远对他不友好，你知道吧？那偷他钱，把他重要道具武器给拿走了，是吧？
这个就那个嘛。
这一下就是给你当头一棒嘛，对吧？所以说社会环境也可以攻击方方面面。
当然人这里啊还有一个常用的啊。
那个攻击你的自由，这个也非常常见啊，困住。
这个一般用场景来解决。你看看啊英雄英雄人物单一大男主的那种戏主角在。
执行任务的过程中，必然有被绑起来关起来。
倒挂起来的时候，你们自己去看。
永远会被攻击人生自由，有时候是场景攻击他，有时候是对手把他绑起来，对吧？就这个有时候是自己犯错。
踩到陷阱，把自己捆起来。所以人身自由啊也是一个常用的被攻击的地方。
下面我就不用给你举例子了吧。
大家就是自己去连了，比如说对手可不可以攻击你的肉体，就直接削你不就完了吗？对手攻击你的精神，对手攻击你的缺陷，对吧？对手偷走你的武器，对吧？对手把你拴起来，对手知道了你假身份的秘密。
对吧都可以攻击呀。
所以你看很多同学老师说哎呀，我写不出剧情，我不知道怎么样大让他贴跌宕起伏。你看你这么去理解，我们用方法去解决这个问题，三个公击员。
三种攻击目标，然后里面再细分一下，你看看你能连出多少种排列组合。
当然不是每一种都适用于你的电影，你也不要给他搞那么满啊。
同学不要就挨个给我来一下啊，挨个来一下，你这个电影就爆了。
你这个主角可能就被攻击死了。
对吧遍体了营沙了。
那个倒没有必要啊。
但是呢。
你可以我说的是共性的问题，就是你们的剧本普遍缺乏攻击性。
你去从这些角度自己去给我连一连线。
连一连线，看能能打出多少种打法。
修改一下你的局。
呃，这种排列组合啊，在你写电视剧的时候。
反而更得心应手，为啥呢？因为你真的可以。
五花八门的都来一遍，因为电视剧它的体量大呀，时长长呀，主角经历的事情多呀。在电影当中啊，你自己选择自己取舍，看你主要想放大哪方面。
但是不要跟我说，你没东西。
没有攻击点，没有攻击性，那你就不对了，只会多不会少。
同学们理解这个表啊，三个这里三个这里三个，然后自己去连。
好不好？这节课就讲这个实用小知识，大家去修改一下你上节课的作业，好吧。
下课吧。